can we play the Magic Johnson clip from
Jimmy Kimmel then I'm going to bring in
watch and say is this what this is all
the tampering charges based on this in
this alone are you not allowed to speak
to him no we don't say hi because we
know each other I say and say hey I want
you to come to the Lakers even though
imma be winking like if you know what
that'd be okay is that what this is
based on the Pacers saw that they filed
the paperwork tampering around the time
of the draft let's bring in loads is
that what this is based on Adrian hey
Dan I am told that no that is not what
their charges are based on not whether
they have something else or not
that has some gravity to it we'll find
out but I'm told they did not file the
tampering charges based on that
television interview that they feel
there was significantly more that went
on okay whose invent did our the Pacers
asking the lead to investigate this is
that how this works with the paperwork
yes
so the Pacers filed you know essentially
you're filing a grievance with League
against the Lakers now it's not you're
not filing it directly
it's not magic is the target of this
he's the one that they believe that
there is evidence of tampering with and
that's what the league will investigate
the leak has a law firm that does it but
they'll go through a lot more I mean
they they have the ability the league
does to go through cell phone records
emails those types of things but it's
still very difficult to prove tampering
it just it just is but also isn't there
an invasion of privacy as well if you're
going to go through phone records could
you can you do this we did did draymond
Green tamper with Oklahoma City with
Kevin Durant well the rules are
different for players the rules are
different for players are there a lot of
times we have communication I mean it is
listen it is tampering but the league
has decided that they're not going to
try to legislate player 2 player
communication it is executive coach you
know anybody who's employed by the team
and an on playing role but players can
go out and recruit James Harden was able
to go
to Chris Paul recruit him to Houston
before that July 1 period legally but
don't you think James Harden is going to
say to Mike D'Antoni hey coach just so
you know I'm going to reach out to Chris
white why would you bring somebody right
and that makes sense right yes but
here's the thing with these with the
frustration that the Pacers have and and
other small small to mid market teams
share and why they're watching this one
closely is people accept that like Chris
Paul was going to be a free agent now he
hadn't opted out of his deal yet in the
end he did knocked out he they figured
out a way for him to do a trade and
Clippers get some things back before
July 1 but he was in his walk up to free
agency everybody can live with a
conversation that everyone believes goes
on before July 1 between a player who's
about to become a free agent and then
his free agency July 1 there's sort of
this a gentlemen's agreement in the
league that that goes on what Indiana is
frustrated with and what other teams
smaller market teams is Paul George had
two years left on his contract at least
one full year and then he could have
opted out that the frustration and why
other teams are watching this is they
feel like they're getting targeted by
bigger market teams when guys have
multiple years left on their deal and
they're not accepting of that of that
premise that that premise is over did
magic make it now I view it as the
letter of the law
magic tampered on the Jimmy Kimmel show
you know just like Steve Kerr tampered
with LeBron James when he jokingly said
it on my show in a costume ten ten
thousand dollars when he was with Jones
you you're you're an executive you make
it public
I know I know magics just trying to
entertain and Kimmel is you know the
Laker fan and but but does the league
just look at this and say this is what
you said not in the context of how you
said it this is what you said wink wink
when it comes to pollard now they do and
they're sensitive especially when it's
that out in the open as you know doing
it on a talk show and everybody sees it
the league has to do something and that
is it but that's just going to be a fine
and the teams can live with the fines
it's you know if something if there's a
greater consequence here which is pretty
unlikely but a greater consequence where
it costs you draft picks or the ability
to sign that player in free agency and
those are the most extreme consequences
and those would only be in play if there
was found to be a very extreme you know
level of contact or interaction that
won't that that potentially went on and
so that's what they're going to dig into
but this is not about that television ok
interview it's something beyond that
he's Adrian would generally ESPN senior
NBA insider and host of the woods
podcast Blake Griffin kind of grabbed a
few headlines there where he said you
hadn't Sela Bron ending in Los Angeles
but in New York would you make of that
well I mean it's I think if he leaves I
think this is an hour I don't know that
New York is necessarily on his list has
really ever been I'm not sure they're in
a position for him to walk in and and
you know salary cap wise they have work
to do in New York and it's it's not been
discussed and conversations I've had
with people in the league that New York
is really a focus for him that if he
does leave Cleveland you know I think
the Lakers remain you know significant
you know they're in all-out
LeBron modes with the Lakers and and I
do think if he entertains the idea of
leaving next year you know they're going
to be part of the conversation to say
the least
is there enough they're like what what
is what is Los Angeles have that LeBron
is going to be attracted to aside from
the big market living in Los Angeles and
what he wants to do after the NBA but
are there enough pieces there where
LeBron can be the savior coming in and
maybe lead them back to the promised
land I don't think there are and I don't
know if there are anywhere I don't know
because of Golden State I don't know any
team LeBron goes to is instantly a
contender I mean they just are but are
they good enough to beat Golden State I
don't know if that team exists maybe
a San Antonio or a place where he took a
little less money but I don't know that
those are realistic
I think LA the play is his entertainment
company his business interests beyond
basketball that that starts to be a play
toward that fading into the sunset in
Hollywood and to want to do some things
he's had a lot of success out there
business-wise in entertainment more so
than maybe anybody his production
company and the things they're doing you
know they've they've gotten off to a
great start in that world and only he
knows how much all of that weighs into
it I do think winning is very important
to him but I don't know where the team
is and I'm not sure he and his group
know where's the team that's just
ready-made for me to walk into now if
it's Paul George and LeBron James going
to LA I still don't think that's good
enough with what they have they've still
got to get that Luol Deng contract off
which is going to cost them a lot in LA
to get someone to take that money off
them their hands I don't know that
there's a team that where he walks into
it all of a sudden they're good enough
to beat the Warriors that the Warriors
have created something that I don't know
if you know Chris Paul going to Houston
that team is better
are they good enough to beat the
Warriors I don't know that any of us
think that but it can Kyrie and LeBron
coexist for one more year and then go
their separate ways it's possible I mean
we've seen it happen I think for the
Cavaliers they would like to do a Kyrie
Irving deal before the season but they
don't have great offers right now they
don't have off they have offers that
they sort of know they could do at any
point so why why do it now the one date
that the Cavs are looking at is December
15th when the Spree the players who
signed free agent deals this past summer
are eligible to be traded on December
15th and that opens up a lot of avenues
for the Cavs
for potential deals because right now
they're not getting the kind of offers
that they want for him and it may
behoove them to just wait but that
creates a circus like training camp and
all that comes with that when he returns
and that's coming Thank You woods we
appreciate it they stand thought you sit
and Riaan will general ski ESPN senior
NBA insider the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience